[MUSIC PLAYING]
JERZY FORYCIARZ: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I'm really glad to
see you all here.
I hope you enjoyed the first
two days as much as we did.
I'm here on the stage
with my friend Ignacy,
who is engineering manager
in Google Kubernetes Engine.
My name is Jerzy Foryciarz.
And we're going to talk and
demo a lot of fancy stuff.
But before we do, let's
take a little survey.
Can you please all stand
up for just a little while?
Excellent.
Thank you.
All right.
So those of you who
use horizontal pod
autoscaler on custom
metrics, you may sit down.
All right.
I see a few faces.
Next question is harder.
Those of you who never
had problems figuring out
the podspec, you may sit down.
OK, good, good.
All right.
Those of you who use node
auto-update in production,
you may sit down.
All right.
Those of you who believe
that you should all
use cluster autoscaler in
production, you may sit down.
Thank you.
OK.
That was great.
That was fun.
Thank you very much.
So here's the contract.
In the next 45 to
50 minutes, we are
going to tell you how to
become a hero by setting up
a pool of auto-scaling workers
based on the pub/sub queue.
And then we are
going to tell you
how to not to be defeated
by a wrong podspec using
vertical pod autoscaler who
takes care of it for you.
Then we'll explain how vertical
pod autoscaler will never
get defeated by missing
resources in the cluster
because the cluster
takes care of itself
due to cluster autoscaler
and node autoprovisioning.
And then at the end,
remember "Men in Black"
with this little device?
[BUZZING NOISE]
We'll tell you,
well, you can really
forget about the infrastructure
part because it just works.
So you can focus
on the top part.
OK?
So here's the deal.
Let's get started.
Before we get started,
everybody is talking
about autoscaling these days.
This is important thing.
And you should expect for all
of your workloads to scale.
Scaling is different for your
front end, for your web page,
for the mobile front ends.
And it's different when you
talk about databases or file
systems.
But because Kubernetes was
built with scalability in place,
and because GKE is the best
hosted version of Kubernetes,
you should have
super-high expectations
about what's happening.
All right, so before we
go there, a quick recap.
What's happening at Kubernetes?
Kubernetes is very simple.
In Kubernetes, you
have a podspec.
In the podspec,
you're saying, well,
here's my Docker container.
I want this many replicas of it.
And, well, this is the amount
of resources I want to use.
Once you have it, you give
the config file to Kubernetes
master.
You put the container
image to the repository.
And then Kubernetes master
is consulting its scheduler
and saying, hello,
dear scheduler.
Could you please tell me
where is the best place
I can deploy this very pod.
So scheduler is looking at
the lower layer on the picture
where all of the nodes are
located and saying, here.
And then Kubernetes downloads
the pod from the repository
and deploys it on the cluster.
And then it's maintaining
it through its life.
So whatever happens
with the pod,
it will get restarted
by Kubernetes
as that is watching it.
It's always going
to be there for you.
Now, as you saw in
this picture, we
are, in fact, talking
about more than one layer.
You have the
infrastructure layer
on the bottom where
your virtual machines
or your physical machines are.
We call them nodes
in Kubernetes.
And then you have
the work load layer.
And this is the fancy layer.
This is the abstraction layer
where everything is beautiful
and you just deploy your pods.
And we expect you
to just have fun
deploying your pods without
worrying about the lower part.
So because of that, and
because of these two layers,
you in fact have also more than
one dimension of autoscaling.
So in the upper layer, well,
you start from horizontal pod
autoscaling.
You have the pods.
And in case of the workloads
that you can load balance
in any way, like your mobile
front end or your website,
well, if there is more
traffic, you need more pods.
If there is less traffic,
you should need less pods.
And autoscaler does it for you.
And this works well.
But not always
because in some cases
you actually need to
change the pod requests.
You may want to say, I want
double the amount of processor
or triple the amount of memory.
And that's the
vertical scaling of it.
That's a totally
different image.
And that was the workload
layer, the fancy layer.
And now realistically, then,
you have this other layer.
And it's different between
the on premises and the cloud.
On premises, well, you pretty
much have what you have.
So that's your sunk cost.
And the best you can
do is to use them all.
Ideally, just use 100 percent
CPU utilization on them
and be done.
Nobody ever achieved that,
but it's like, use them.
In the cloud, you
don't have to do that.
In the cloud, in fact,
you have the ability
to request exactly what you
need and then use it only
when you need it.
And this goes a long way.
Like, you may request
specific types
of machines that are
having the amount of memory
and the number, of course, that
exactly correspond to what you
want to deploy on top of it.
You may want to
request something
that is even more sophisticated
because it has a graphics
accelerator.
All of that is
possible in the cloud.
Not so much, and without any
flexibility, on premises.
So now, well, on the
infrastructure layer
in the cloud, you also
have abilities to scale.
This goes roughly the same way.
Meaning, well, if there
are more workloads deployed
from the workload
layer, then you're
going to need more nodes
in the infrastructure layer
to handle it.
So the idea here is to
reactively, very quickly,
get you the appropriate
type of a node
and remove them as soon
as they're not needed.
So this is something
that we call
a cluster autoscaler,
so autoscaler number
three in this story.
And then there is
one more piece.
And this one more
piece, I'm very proud.
It's an alpha, and it's
coming to beta hopefully
later this summer.
It's called node
auto-provisioning.
And it's getting a
different type of nodes
depending on what you need.
And you don't need to
really worry about it.
So we are going to
talk piece by piece
about all of these
four dimensions,
giving you great demos.
My friend is resting
here in the corner,
but he'll be up to
speed in a second.
All right.
So here in the story, we have
four dimensions of autoscaling.
HBA, elsewhere call it
Horizontal Pod Autoscaler,
more pods based on the
utilization matrix.
Vertical Pod Autoscaler,
different pod sizes,
right amount.
Cluster autoscaler, more
nodes based on pending pods
in the scheduler.
And then node
auto-provisioning, all together
they are different node pools
and the overall scheduling
optimizer.
This is what we're
going to talk about.
So let's talk about horizontal
pod autoscaling in practice.
So this is an example of a
workload that is load balanced.
So imagine we have
four pods on the left.
And what you see on the right
is their CPU utilization
expressed in terms of
how much the pod is using
versus what was requested.
So as you can see, these
pods are running hot.
But if you manage
to add one more pod,
then the load balancer
that you're using
can spread the workload
across more pods.
And through this, the average
utilization will be lower.
And the same story will happen
if you go the other direction.
Imagine you were at
the stage like this.
All of the pods were running
below 50% of CPU utilization.
Now we must say, well, we are
heating up the data center.
50% of our cores are
basically doing nothing.
So in the ideal case, we would
just remove one of these pods
and get the load denser
on the other four.
So pretty much this
all comes to a target.
You set a target
and you say, I want
my workload to run, on average,
across all pods I deployed,
around something like this,
which is maybe like 60%, say.
And then autoscaler is getting
the workload to that state.
It's adding more
pods when needed.
It's removing them
where not needed,
observing all of the loads
of your cluster as they are.
So that was the situation where
you have the state proportional
to the number of requests.
But it's not always the case.
And that's why we have something
that we call custom metrics.
In the situation
of custom metrics,
you may extract any
metrics from your system.
And this can be number
of requests per seconds.
This can be latencies
of your system.
This can finally be
something like backlog
of tasks in the task
queue, which we have here.
So imagine there is
a very simple queue.
We use Pub/Sub queue
because we are Google.
But you may use any other queue.
It can be RabbitMQ.
It can be whatever, ZooKeeper.
And then you have producers
that deliver a piece of data
to be processed and
register this fact
in the queue as a message.
And then you have workers
that pick up this message
and start to process it.
And then at the end,
you have autoscaler.
And what the autoscaler
is doing is making sure
that there is enough workers
to get this data processed
in a timely manner.
That's how it works.
Super powerful.
Tens and tens of customers
that we talked to that
just need a system
like that in order
to process data workloads
in a timely manner
in a very controlled way.
So let's get started.
I'm going to invite Ignacy
Kowalczyk to stage to walk you
through the first part.
So you can switch to the other--
IGNACY KOWALCZYK: --everyone.
And thank you, Jerzy,
for a great introduction
to autoscaling in GKE.
So it's going to be
my pleasure today
to demonstrate how all these
dimensions of autoscaling
actually work in GKE.
I'm going to start with, in
the first part of my demo,
with setting up
the horizontal pod
autoscaler for the pool of
workers that will be consuming
tasks from a message queue.
These are going to be
three simple steps.
First of all, we're going to set
up the workers, the task queue.
The second step
will be configuring
the autoscaler that's
based on the size of the,
or the number of
elements in the queue.
We'll autoscale the workers.
And finally, we'll add
some tasks into the queue,
just to see the system rolling.
All right, but
before I get started,
let me show you the
environment we are using here,
so basically what
cluster I'm using.
So as you can see, there's a
quite funny name of a cluster.
But it's actually a
development cluster
so that I can show you some
of the cool features of VPN
Cluster Autoscaler that
are not launched yet.
All right.
Let's take a little bit
closer look at the cluster.
So I'm going to check
what nodes do I have here.
So my cluster is actually
running five nodes,
each of them being
n1-standard-1 VMs in GCE.
OK, so I've got my cluster.
So the next thing
is the workload.
I actually set up my worker
pool before this presentation
has started, as well, through
a deployment controller.
So deployment is called worker.
Now, let's take a look at the
definition of this deployment.
So the important thing is
we've got two replicas.
So we start with
two worker tasks.
All these talks will have
the label [? app:worker ?]
assigned.
And you might also notice
that because finding
the right podspec
is so difficult,
I just didn't set any
requests for my memory.
So going back to the
console, so next thing,
once we have the workers, let's
check out our message queue.
So as Jerzy mentioned,
we're using cloud Pub/Sub.
So we've got one
topic defined which
the producers will be using to
publish tasks into the message
queue.
And we have one
subscription that
is called a worker's
subscription
that's letting the
consumers consume messages
from the worker task queue.
Our setup is such
that each worker task
is consuming messages from
a single subscription.
So therefore, what you're
modeling is effectively a task
queue where each
task in the queue
will be delivered to
exactly one worker.
All right, so now the next step,
once we have worker, queue,
now horizontal pod autoscaler.
So let me create
horizontal pod autoscaler.
Am I in the right directory?
Yes.
All right.
So let's take a look
again at the definition
of this horizontal
pod autoscaler.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JERZY FORYCIARZ:
It hasn't started.
IGNACY KOWALCZYK: Ah, sorry.
Yeah, this is a
live demo, you see?
I didn't pray to the demo
gods that well, possibly.
Thank you.
All right, so back
to the definition
of our horizontal
pod autoscaler.
So the interesting
bit here is that we
are using number of pending
messages in our queue
as a scaling metric.
This is an external metric.
This is supposed in the
V2 version, of V2 API
of horizontal pod autoscaler.
Now, the target average
value, what does it mean?
That means that we want
to have, on average,
25 messages in our
queue per every pod
replica in our deployment.
So roughly that means we
want one worker processing
the tasks per every
25 tasks in the queue.
And as you can see, we
are also, obviously,
pointing our horizontal pod
autoscaler at the worker
deployment down here.
All right, so now let's
take a closer look
at this horizontal pod
autoscaler using kubectl.
So the horizontal
pod autoscaler has
been successfully recreated.
The name of the HPA
is queue scaler.
Now the interesting
column that I
want to drag your attention
to is the targets column.
So this is where, actually, the
target metric is represented.
So the value zero
means that currently we
have zero messages in the
queue for every worker
in our deployment while
the target value is 25.
The reason why horizontal pod
autoscaler is not scaling down
our deployment is
that, actually, we
have set up the minimum and
maximum number of pod replicas
for our deployment.
And the minimum number
is two, so we're
kind of staying with
two replicas here.
All right, with that we are
moving to the third step, which
is, let's add some
messages into the queue
to see things rolling.
So I have a little script
that will be adding tasks.
And I'm going to show you
how this script actually
looks like.
Again, a super simple thing.
So this basically generates 100
messages into our worker tasks
topic, and doing so with
[INAUDIBLE] and messages
in each.
So this seems to be
pretty simple mechanism.
But actually the cool thing is
that is a very powerful design
pattern.
In fact, last year
on the Next 2017
we showcased
together with Airbus
their solution where they were
processing satellite images
exactly with this approach.
So what they've been
doing is they've
been publishing the images to
be transcoded into the message
queue.
And then they were running
a horizontally scaled pool
of workers that were
processing these tasks.
And obviously,
horizontal pod autoscaler
was managed to find
a good trade-off
between the performance of
the system and the cost.
So in the meantime, I hope
my message is good at it.
OK.
And then let's see what
horizontal pod autoscaler has
to say about it now.
All right, so what we see
is that the metric is still
zero, which means our horizontal
pod autoscaler did not
pick up yet the new metric from
the Cloud Pub/Sub quite yet.
So we can--
OK.
It's growing.
It's 25 now.
So it's picking up.
But basically, the thing is that
what is happening right now,
horizontal pod autoscaling is
getting new updates from Cloud
Pub/Sub, with the magic
being number of messages
in the queue.
So in the meantime, I hope
that our deployment has already
been autoscaled.
So all right, still
we have only two.
So let's take a look
at horizontal pod
autoscaler again--
still 25, slow
delivery of metrics.
We have to wait a little bit.
Maybe I can take some
questions in the meantime.
AUDIENCE: Can you
raise your terminal
so we can see it better, please?
JERZY FORYCIARZ: Well, oh--
IGNACY KOWALCZYK: Ah, sure, yes.
That was a good point.
Is it any better?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
IGNACY KOWALCZYK: Awesome.
Still 25.
All right.
Any more questions, then?
JERZY FORYCIARZ: OK, so I
propose that while we're
waiting for this one,
let's talk about what
can go wrong with this story.
Is that a good idea?
And in the meantime,
we'll see what happens.
IGNACY KOWALCZYK: Sure.
JERZY FORYCIARZ: OK,
so let's switch back
to this slides for a second.
So provided this is actually
firing up the way it should--
well, demo gods.
We're [INAUDIBLE],,
so maybe that's why.
Well, if this worked,
it was all good.
Now, could anything go wrong?
IGNACY KOWALCZYK: I got it.
JERZY FORYCIARZ: OK, back.
Please, back to the demo slide.
IGNACY KOWALCZYK: Thank you.
All right.
So--
JERZY FORYCIARZ: Can we get
back to the demo screen?
IGNACY KOWALCZYK: Thank you.
JERZY FORYCIARZ: OK.
IGNACY KOWALCZYK: All right,
so re-trying and trying, we
got 50.
So this is the value that
I was expecting you to see.
We generated 100 messages
and we have two workers.
So the average per worker is 50.
Why the target was 25?
So again, let's take a look
at our deployment, then.
And the deployment
is the controller
that runs my worker tasks.
And voila.
So right now we have four
worker tasks deployed.
JERZY FORYCIARZ: Yeah,
your four workers.
IGNACY KOWALCZYK: So.
JERZY FORYCIARZ: All right.
Very good.
IGNACY KOWALCZYK: Horizontal
pod autoscaler works.
JERZY FORYCIARZ: Very good.
It worked.
IGNACY KOWALCZYK: Back to Jerzy.
[APPLAUSE]
JERZY FORYCIARZ: Thank you.
Yeah, give him a
round of applause.
All right, so back to
the slides, please.
So yes, besides demo gods,
nothing else can go wrong, huh?
Well, not quite.
We've been actually
surveying you for a reason.
Well, realistically,
how many of you
run very detailed
performance tests every time
you deploy a new deployment?
OK, 1, 2, 3.
OK.
And deployments typically
do per day in Kubernetes?
I'm assuming a lot.
And in that case, this
may get problematic if all
of the sudden this situation
changes in your pod,
and you do not correct
it in the podspec.
So imagine in this situation--
we're obviously setting up
for that to demonstrate--
imagine in this situation we
started to run out of memory
because the very last build
added just one more feature.
And this one more feature
is using far more memory
than before.
Nothing is wrong with it.
It's just a mismatch between
the kind of virtual space,
which is your
container, which was
requested at this certain
size, and what you really need.
So in that situation,
you go out of memory.
And if you go out of memory,
what's going to happen?
Your job is going to get
evicted by Kubernetes.
And then scheduler will see it.
And because I promise that
Kubernetes will always
take care of your pods,
they'll get recreated.
And after a while, they'll
get evicted and so on.
Well, there is
another possibility.
There is, in fact,
a race condition
because Unix is also very smart.
So may, in fact, get your
application reset by Linux
before it gets evicted.
But in either case,
you're going to get
in this vicious cycle of not
having your workload running.
So with that in mind, we
built vertical pod autoscaler.
So vertical pod autoscaler
is a piece of beauty.
It does roughly this.
It looks at your
workload, decides here,
whatever we have in the
95% and the remaining five,
this was your pod.
Let's say this was your pod
expressed in CPU utilization.
And now vertical pod autoscaler
is saying, ha, ha, ha.
Just request a bigger
machine for that.
So you get a bigger machine.
And all of a sudden,
you're not running
90% of the utilization
of that space.
You're running 70.
The [? world ?] is saved.
So now how do we do this?
We do it in a very simple
way, through three steps.
First one is vertical
pod autoscaler
is watching the utilization.
Does it do it for
every pod you have?
No.
You actually have to turn it
on and you have to tell us--
or, well, tell vertical
pod autoscaler--
what is the label.
What pods do you want to watch?
Once you do this,
vertical pod autoscaler
consulting the metrics
server and it's
calculating the recommendation.
And at minimum, it's just
providing the recommendation.
And then also, you can
enable automatic update mode,
and I'll talk to you
about it in a second.
You can, in fact, actuate.
But at minimum, this
[INAUDIBLE] podspec?
Well, assume for a while that
you actually pulled the request
for memory on CPU.
Well, and it was
wrong for some reason.
So what vertical pod
autoscaler is doing
is consulting metric server.
It looks at the piece on the
left, which is your spec.
And on the right, it's
outputting a very simple
recommendation.
And this recommendation
is in the middle.
It says target.
And it says, well,
CPU, two cores,
memory has certain amounts.
And then it's also
providing a range.
And the range is for the updater
to either take action or not
take action.
If you're not
outside of the range,
there is probably no
reason for you to update,
even if the target is
somewhere in between.
So that's how it works.
So now we have two
modes of update,
if you choose to use it.
One is only
happening at the time
of creating of the new pod.
So whenever a new
pod gets created,
vertical pod autoscaler is
reading what's in the podspec.
And it's also comparing it
with the recommendation.
And if that's wrong
or if there is
a mismatch outside
of the safety wrench,
then it applies correction.
So in fact, the pod that's
going to get deployed
has a correct request.
It doesn't mean that the
podspec was corrected.
It's just, well,
vertical pod autoscaler
knows better and does it right.
And then there is a second
mode that we call full auto,
that we're, by the
way, going to use here
in a second, that does it,
also, for all running pods.
In fact, it's observing
the pod disruption budget.
It is taking pods one by one,
draining them, and recreating
or forcing to get
recreated that so
that they can just get adjusted.
So that's it.
And you may ask, I probably
already spoiled it,
but you may ask, will
they play together?
So the answer is yes.
And the answer is
also, well, however,
don't try it with the
horizontal pod autoscaling
running on CPU
utilization because this
is the same metrics.
It's not working quite yet.
So on everything else,
we promised it's working.
And with this, back to
Ignacy to demonstrate.
IGNACY KOWALCZYK:
Thank you, Jerzy.
All right, so in this
part of the demo,
I'm going to use
vertical pod autoscaler.
And as you remember,
I was quite naive.
I didn't set any memory
requests for my application.
And this makes me a
little bit anxious.
You know, I deployed it,
and I kind of hope it runs.
So I will investigate the memory
consumption of my application.
And then I'll use
vertical pod autoscaler
to actually check
whether I was right
or whether the system
is running well.
And then finally,
I'm actually going
to be convinced by the
VPA recommendations.
And I will turn on the automated
actuation of vertical pod
autoscaler recommendation.
OK, so let's go to see what's
happening in production.
So I'm going to Stackdriver.
And I have a little
dashboard here,
which presents me the memory
consumption of my worker tasks
deployment.
Doesn't look good, really.
So what is happening here?
All these worker
tasks are basically
growing the memory consumption
quite fast up to some point.
And then they are
kind of disappearing.
So this is worrying me.
So I'm going to take
a look at my pods.
So let's go use kubectl again.
Whoa.
So yes, I've got a
couple of them running.
But then I have also a
bunch of them evicted.
So indeed, something
is killing my pods.
I've seen them growing
to roughly around,
like, 2.5 gigs of
memory consumption,
as far I remember from
this [INAUDIBLE] dashboard.
So I'm going to check my
nodes, how much memory actually
the notes have.
So the reason is
I'm checking it is
that if I don't set
memory requests,
I'm pretty much free to use
most of the available memory
or resources on the nodes.
Most of it.
Kubernetes will take care that
there is some extra margin.
All right, so I have
this little command line
that I'm going to
be typing here,
which basically using kubectl,
I'm enumerating my nodes again.
But this time, I
also want to check
what is the amount
of allocatable memory
on these nodes.
All right, so they
have 2.7 gigs of RAM.
These n1-standard-1 VMs have
2.7 gigs of allocatable memory
to user pods.
So this is close to what I
was observing on Stackdriver.
OK, so I have my suspicion
already that basically my pods
need more memory.
So with that, let's try
to consult vertical pod
autoscaler.
So right now I'm creating
a vertical pod autoscaler.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE],
IGNACY KOWALCZYK: [SIGHS] Again.
All right, and
it's being created.
Now let me switch
to presentation
to show you in bigger
letters what's been done.
So I have created a
vertical pod autoscaler.
And the interesting bits
of these configurations
are, first of all,
matching by label.
So vertical pod autoscaler is
different than horizontal pod
autoscaler.
You don't point VPA at
specific controllers,
such as deployment
or replica set.
Instead, it is a little
bit more flexible.
And you can select
specific pods that you
want the VPA to generate
a recommendation
for through a label query.
In this case, it's app worker.
Now, the next important
piece of configuration
here is the update policy.
So in this case, I set
the update modes to off
because all I want
to know is I want
to see VPAs recommendations.
And all I'm hoping
that this will give me
some more clues about what's
going on in the system.
As a reminder, we can also
set up the update modes
to auto, in which case the
vertical pod autoscaler would
do the rolling
update of all my pods
that are matching the
label query and recreating
them, basically killing them and
letting them be scheduled again
with the new resource requests.
The reason is that currently
in Kubernetes, there
is no functionality,
there's no capability
of adjusting the
resource requests
and limits for running pods.
So you basically have
to kill them and let
them be re-scheduled
again by the scheduler
with the new requests.
All right, so in the
meantime, let's see
if our VPA has generated any
good recommendations for us.
All right, it did, actually.
So there is this, in VPA
resource, which is a customer
service definition, we've got
this recommendation section
where we see that
our VPA says, hmm,
these worker tasks should
be probably running
at a target of 3.5 gigs
of RAM memory request.
So this is totally not
something that my infrastructure
is prepared for.
My nodes were 2.6 gigs.
So I'm going to
be very naive now.
I don't want to deal
with infrastructure.
I just want to actuate vertical
pod autoscaler's decision.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to edit this VPA.
And I'm going to change
only one parameter, which
is the update mode.
So I'm changing to auto.
Boom.
And let's see what will happen.
In the meantime, I'm
heading over to Jerzy.
JERZY FORYCIARZ: All right.
So let's go back to slides.
So now we're going to
let the magic happen.
In the meantime, let's talk
about the proper magic.
So in this section, we're
going to talk about the cluster
autoscaling.
[? And you'll see ?] you
may expect what would happen
in the normal situation.
We would have the
automation that we set up,
the vertical pod autoscaler
to attempt killing the pods.
And then we would
attempt to recreate them
with a different pod request.
The pod request
would have been--
the memory request would have
been something around 3.2,
if I remember.
So that would be pending.
So we would literally
kill our set up forever,
until somebody on the operator
site, on your DevOps side,
would have realized,
well, something is wrong.
We cannot-- these
are not scheduled.
So luckily, this is
not how it's working.
We told you you can forget
about the infrastructure
because the infrastructure
is not forgetting about you.
So this is exactly
what's happening here.
Cluster autoscaler works
through observing the pod
requests and, based
on these requests,
making a decision or suggestion.
So what you have
here is a scheduler.
And the scheduler is,
in a normal situation,
is looking at the pod's requests
and it's placing a note.
So if there is enough
resources on the node-- sorry,
it's [? plaguing ?] the pod.
If there is enough resources
on a node to deploy a pod,
it's simply happening.
But there may be a situation if
there is not enough resources
and you necessarily need
to add one node, like this.
Well, there is an
operation involved.
What it this triggered by?
This is triggered by the
pending pods, nothing else.
No utilization of any kind.
The reaction is to,
well, do I need more?
In some cases, you
may be in a situation
like this, which is even more
annoying because now you have
too many nodes, it looks like.
Too many nodes.
So in the ideal
case, you would have
done some kind of a defrag.
Realistically, move
one of the pods
somewhere else so that
you can remove the node
and have a better utilization,
a better price of performance,
as you may say.
So this is all done by
the cluster autoscaler.
Cluster autoscaler is doing
literally two functions.
And within each of
those, other three.
So it watches the pending
pods, first of all.
It's just seeing what the
scheduler would be seeing.
And the pending
pod means there is
no space in the infrastructure
for the pod to be scheduled.
And then it simulates
the scheduler
by trying to look into what
would have happened if I added
one or two or three nodes.
Would the deployment
actually land?
And would all of the
pods be scheduled?
If that's the case, then yes.
Cluster autoscaler
triggers adding nodes.
This is done by the part
of the infrastructure.
But the decision counts
from the cluster autoscaler.
Now, in the same time, it
also watches the utilization.
But it only watches it for the
construction of the cluster.
So if any node is running
below some set utilization,
right now I believe
we have it set to 50%,
this is a trigger to look
around for the-- this
is a trigger for a
cluster autoscaler
to look around and make
some checks, right?
What would have happened
if we deleted that machine?
Would all pods be rescheduled?
Or are they in the system
nodes running there
and that would be
a big disruption?
How would that play with
the pod disruption budget?
If it's possible, the decision
comes to train and delete
the node, and then
the scheduler is
rescheduling the pods that were
running there somewhere else.
And through this, we have
a better package system.
So that was a very
intro work through.
But the real cluster autoscaler
looks something like that
because in a cluster, you don't
just have one type of nodes.
Well, you could.
But in most cases, you are
deploying more than one type
of the workload, more
than one size of the pods.
And it's very hard,
unless you manage
to deploy super big nodes that
can accommodate everything
and you don't care for the
empty space surrounding on them,
it's really super
hard to optimize it
with just one type of nodes.
That's why the good
practice that we
were suggesting, and was
there for at least last year,
maybe a year and a half,
was to use in node pools.
Node pools are groups
of identical nodes
within the cluster.
And example like
this one is where
you have some small nodes,
some medium, and some big.
And through this, the
cluster autoscaler
does a little bit different job.
It is monitoring the state
of the entire cluster,
but it's also--
whenever there is
a pending pod, it's
actually simulating
the action of scheduler
across all of the node pools.
So what would that
have been if we
enlarge one of this, or the
other one, or the other one?
Well, this is a very
simple example when
you look at this single pod.
But the pods are
coming in all the time,
and they are of different sizes.
So realistically, there is lots
of interesting combinatorics
coming in.
But thanks to this, you
end up getting very well
and tight packaged cluster.
So when the recommendation
is placed then
the new node is added in
the node pool of a choosing
by the cluster autoscaler, and
then the pod gets deployed.
Now, there may be a
situation similar to what
we're setting our demo for,
that despite the fact that we
already have three types
of node pools, three
sizes of node pools, we now
arrive with the pod that
wouldn't fit to any of those.
And before November,
late November
last year, that would
be the moment where
your system would get stuck.
And it would have
to wait for someone
to notice there is a problem.
Luckily, and this
feature is now in alpha
and it's coming to
beta later this summer,
we have node
autoprovisioning, which
is like a consultant to
the cluster autoscaler.
So cluster autoscaler
is not only
running the simulation
looking at all three
of these node pools.
But in fact, it's consulting
node autoprovisioning saying,
what if there was another one?
And if there was, what
would be the size?
And then at the end,
it decides there
is a new node pool needed.
It creates one.
And then the pod gets deployed.
Now throughout this
talk, we are telling you
you can forget about
node provisioning.
So we're just
explaining it to you
so that you see
how simple it is.
But we leave you
very little control,
just like you are switching
a cluster autoscaler simply
on and off.
And you also get as
a budget the minimum
and the maximum of
RAM of CPU, you just
enable autoprovisioning.
You don't need to
worry about this layer.
This layer just does the
job for your higher layer.
The higher layer is
where your workload is,
so you better know
what's happening.
This one is just
adjusting to get you
the best cost for performance.
OK, so that's roughly it.
So let me just walk you
through what just happened.
And then we're going to have
a look into the demo again.
So we had a horizontal
pod autoscaler
set to look at the
Pub/Sub queue as parameter
and autoscale so that
for every 25 tasks,
there was at least
one worker deployed.
We had vertical pod
autoscaler to watch,
after we enabled it
into the auto mode, now
it's watching if there
is everything right
with the requests of resources.
And if not, we actually
set it to auto.
And as a result, whenever
the request is wrong,
it will get adjusted.
And then on the
infrastructure layer,
the cluster autoscaler is
observing the unscheduled pods.
And it's actually
consulting with the VPA
so that this process
doesn't happen prematurely
in an awkward way.
We don't want all of the
pods to be killed first
and then be pending later.
So in fact, there is a loopback,
which there is a translation of
are these resources
already prepared?
And only if they are,
the update is happening.
Most of the real life cases
don't happen that drastically.
They happen every
once in a while.
And then the node
autoprovisioning
is a consultant to the
cluster autoscaler.
It's making it more optimal.
So as you can see, you
have four autoscaler.
But in fact, you
have one system that
is autoscaling all of it
for you by having all four
layers talking in unison.
So that's what we have.
And now are we ready?
IGNACY KOWALCZYK: Yeah.
JERZY FORYCIARZ: All right.
IGNACY KOWALCZYK:
Well, we'll see.
All right, thanks, Jerzy.
So this is the final
step of our demo.
So we're going to
see what happens.
So remember, I was playing
only with pod autoscaler--
sorry, horizontal pod autoscaler
and vertical pod autoscaler.
And thankfully, I got my cluster
set up with this smart node
autoprovisioning and
cluster autoscaler
enabled so that I did not
care about my nodes at all.
So now let's see what happened.
So I'm going back
to the console.
And I have my little script
that brings the pods,
but also brings the--
let me show it to
you, actually--
but also brings the memory
requests of those pods.
So remember, when I set up
the podspec for my deployment,
the memory units were empty.
So let's see what they are now.
So again, you have
all these evicted pods
that we had before, but we
also have four running pods.
And all these pods have
actually the memory request
set to 3.5 five gigs, which
was the recommendation
of vertical pod autoscaler.
So woohoo, this works.
And they are running now.
Now how is it possible,
given that I had
five nodes with 2.7 gigs each?
So let's take a
look at the nodes.
I'm using my old script--
JERZY FORYCIARZ:
Before we go there,
the historical data that
we are showing there
is like all of the failed nodes.
But you look at the
four that are running.
We requested four to be running,
and there are four running.
IGNACY KOWALCZYK: So indeed,
we have our original v5 nodes
in the default node pool.
But we also have a new
n1-standard-2 VMs in a new node
pool, created automatically by
all the node autoprovisioner.
And these guys are running
5 gigs of RAM each.
And thanks to that, our
worker task gets scheduled.
So it all works.
Let me take a look
at the final--
at the Stackdriver
chart, refresh it,
and let's see if
it looks better.
Indeed.
We see that the workers
grew to bigger memory usage
than before.
They were allowed to and
they are stabilizing.
They are running at this level.
So wow.
[APPLAUSE]
JERZY FORYCIARZ: All right.
OK, so let's go back to slides.
This was great.
So we hope you see
that you can really
forget about node provisioning.
Well, in fact, you can set it
up and almost observe that it
occasionally goes to zero or
almost to zero because there
are still some system-level
polls that needs to be running
and only--
or are that when you need it.
So you may wonder, is that all?
It should be all because we
have one more minute and then
questions.
But, well, one more thing.
Well, wouldn't it be
great if that also worked
with the graphics accelerators?
Well, it does.
With the new release
that's coming to beta soon,
node autoprovisioning will
be capable of scheduling
your nodes with the
graphics accelerators.
So now imagine this
very precious resource
that is super expensive gets
super automatically provisioned
only when you need it.
So you deploy your
pod, your pod request
just has one extra line.
And it says what type
of graphics card I want.
And to the four steps
that we were describing--
in fact, three, because
the horizontal pod
autoscaler doesn't need to be
part of it, you'll just get it.
And then whenever it's not
needed, it will be removed.
But in fact, a while ago you
saw there were four new nodes.
And there were also
still all the old nodes.
They're going to get removed.
There is a cycle loop that's
running every 10 minutes, so
in a while--
we've been speaking
for very short time.
In a while, they
will get removed
because this is how it works.
All right, so--
IGNACY KOWALCZYK: And just, you
can also imagine the direction
where it's going is
that it doesn't have
to be only size of the
nodes and only GPUs,
but whatever infrastructure
requirements of your workload.
So basically the idea is
you specify declaratively
the requests, the requirements
from the infrastructure
in your podspecs or
in your controllers.
That's it.
You don't have to care
about the infrastructure.
The right infrastructure
will be provisioned for you
by node autoprovisioning.
JERZY FORYCIARZ: All right.
So that's all.
Now we have a couple of
minutes for questions.
And then we'll be outside
to take more questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]